young boy three years old shot two
people inside his home recently his mom
and a friend of his moms and it turns
out the friend of his mom was wanted for
murder so when they found him in the
hospital they arrested him did the kid
just find a gun and pick it up and start
firing and the mom got hit or the mom
was like Hey time out for you and the
kid was like I don't think so have you
ever seen a three-year-old try to hold a
gun they can't it's like it's way too
big for them their hands are just little
I wonder what kind of gun it was is it
like a three-year-old gun or was it like
a big big boy gun I would imagine you
accidentally shoot someone your first
thought being like oh I hope I just shot
a murderer so you think he shot the guy
he shot the mom's boyfriend because for
justice and then was like well she's
right there I gotta I gotta teach her
about be careful Who Your Friends Are